hey leute willkommen zu locken ist arg
nummer 13 heute ist freitag der
dreizehnte und gestern bin ich aus köln
zurück nach berlin gefahren nach sechs
tagen in absoluter ekstase bin ich auch
ganz schön froh gewesen endlich mal
wieder in meinem eigenen bett schlafen
zu können und berlin war genauso kalt
und hässlich und sexy wie es in
erinnerung behalten habe naja stimmt
aber du bist zurück in meinem blog in
meinem revier habe ich will jetzt meine
ganzen typischen aufmachen
irgendjemand hat einen die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich eklige zähne
optimum was sagst du dazu absolut
überhaupt
der wunderschöne gelbe farbe finde ich
auch
ich habe so viel kaffee getrunken und so
viele zigaretten darauf dafür mit
deutscher akkurat halt so ist die natur
programmtitel meter statt
sehen sie verliebt sie glauben ein meter
zieht
ich sehe so fix und alle aus
ich glaube irgendwie das glaubt man sich
nur fertig machen und was noch heftig
grafik ein leider ist man sehr wichtig
dass ich auch was ich will sind
vielleicht nicht in griffiger ein land
das nicht so
endlich an meine tür aufmachen und so
bestimmt
die nachbarn haben alle karten unten an
die tür geklebt und haben sich bei dem
nikolaus bedankt der sie dieses mal so
richtig geschenkt hat fand ich voll sie
schaut mal ich habe das so komische sind
so nach von einfach dieses video
wahrscheinlich niemals sehen werden und
niemanden gerissen hatten gereicht ich
noch mal leben
warum kriegt den denn die jetzt nicht zu
nikolaus denk ich denke zuerst an etwas
das du täglich ganz selbstständig öfter
okay das ist doch das gleiche
saeco schön weißt du was nämlich kelly
gesagt hat ich war richtig traurig wir
haben uns ja nikolaus gesehen und dann
habe ich ihren schoko nikolaus
mitgebracht und dann hat sie noch gesagt
aber ich bin heute morgen aufgestanden
war so traurig ein schoko nikolaus
kriege aber nicht hat sie nicht gedacht
sie hätten nichts für mich für nikolaus
[Musik]
da hat er richtig geguckt
doch je höher der braut schön wie
genspuren war aber dann besucht hier
können wir ihn hier ganz okay beobachtet
einen sonnenuntergang oder einen
sonnenaufgang es gibt nur wenige dinge
die dich so gegenwärtig sind am
sonnenaufgang und -untergang beobachte
ich auch was wir machen sollen aufgang
mit der drohne
heute machen sie eigentlich wirklich gut
und muss einmal frieden hält das war
voll cool mal morgens raus zu gehen und
den sonnenaufgang habe ich ja noch mal
dass ich an etwas sehr wohl kenne
überhaupt keine weihnachtsstimmung der
wohnung gibt es allerlei madoff tribune
nimm die zu einer beliebigen tageszeit
einen moment um dich auf einen atemzug
zu können sind renate einen kanal aus
konzentriere deine aufmerksamkeit darauf
er sich an so besetzt zielgenauer den
morgen
daran erkenne ich doch ziemlich can t be
orf er hin wer ungewollt ich da wenn
timo der schokolade schenken will aber
weiß dass du laktose nicht verträgt kann
die herrschaft ist okay ich habe den
mund geschaut dass da keine kann spuren
von links ganze haben ja ja ja immer
geguckt dass da kein milchpulver sondern
kann man fügt dann selber mich hin zu
hören kannst du deine freiheit oder die
haben mir so richtig
was sicherlich das von lin gibt wusste
dankbarkeit setze dich heute mit
jemanden in verbindung der einen
positiven einfluss auf dein leben hatte
und danke diesen menschen die dank
botschaft kann in jeder form erfolgen
per e-mail kurznachricht mit einem anruf
oder persönlich die nachricht ganz wie
langjährigen freund lehrer
familienmitglieder fraktionen bestimmt
sein denn deine meinung nach etwas
dankbarkeit verdient ja erst mal schön
sich über die tannenbaum doku lustig
machen und jetzt bin ich komplett
ja
immer noch 23 und 30 jahren
türchen nummer ja das ist ein richtiger
holen hamas sei das leide weil auch
immer du heute wartet sei es an der
kasse im supermarkt auf deine
verabredung oder darf es ist ein
computer oder handy etwas lädt ergreife
die gelegenheit aufmerksam zu mädchen
dankbar zu sein oder ein gebet zu
sprechen wie werden wir immer verstauben
ja es ist aber wirklich also ganz
ehrlich es ist ein guter tipp wenn ihr
in der schlange steht oder irgendwas
macht was gerade langweilig oder
unangenehm ist einfach nutzen um sich zu
entspannen
türchen nummer 12 und das ist heute das
türchen
jetzt bin ich wieder aufgeholt noch
einen tee für sich mango da hat der
junge tief in die tasche gegriffen
mach dich schlau krähen protein war die
folge so liebe ich merke schon aber
damit wollte ich mich jetzt ärgern
ja so ist erfahren die natur suche dir
einen park oder irgend eine grünfläche
wo du stehen können wir heute und ich
habe hier die natur
ich muss dein gesicht was ich bin jetzt
kommt noch ein paar zufolge jeden tag so
viel wie kein wort alles hat mir in die
karten dass länder geben
das glaube ich und vier ausgemacht
tischen um 84
die sich gerade hat so diese alten
flecken drauf legen immer früher kaffee
was waren nikolaus in zwei so
eingepackte pralinen ordne aktionskarten
hier könnten 1000 euro drauf sein
die nummer 7 es war schokolade drin
die sieht aber auch schon wieder so
leicht an gegängelt aus edel maximal mit
mandel kirchenmann 9
warum sie guck mal wie alt die aussieht
zwischen immer de 2 schicht nougat ich
möchte auch wieder so alt der ikea
adventskalenders dieses jahr so eine
enttäuschung
milch creme mit orangengeschmack und das
zürcher heute nummer zwölf leute es
halbzeit in zwölf tagen bis weihnachten
in den vatikan stäbchen
es ist schon sehr spät und wir haben
wieder herr der ringe geschaut und
frisch gegessen
doch jetzt gibt es noch eine sache die
ich unbedingt machen möchte und zwar
sind während meiner abwesenheit ein paar
pakete angekommen und ich glaube sogar
ein paket und das wollte ich noch
auspacken
was ist dieser blog heute ich weiß es
nicht ab morgen geht dann wieder richtig
los das ist immer so wenn man unterwegs
ist was will man einen film und zu hause
gibt es ja auch nicht so viel aber ich
hoffe ich habe ich trotzdem in
weihnachtsstimmung bringen mit konsum
dieses paket habe ich gar nicht erwartet
ich glaub ich steh offizier jetzt beide
new balance auf der liste das ist glaube
ich doch auch nix pian liste stehe ich
auch also von dem make up looks von new
balance habe ich sogar diese leggings
die ich trage ich finde die mega gut
deswegen dachte ich komm pack ich es
doch mal vor der kamera aus
wir haben wieder bürger bestellt und ich
habe so einen burger genommen der so
spinat als penny hatte statt fleisch
irgendwie liegt er mir so schärfen magen
weil die alle immer so viele zwiebeln
auf die bürger machen
also das ist keine bezahlte werbung das
habe ich jetzt nur zugeschickt bekommen
liebe vanessa vielen dank für die tolle
zusammenarbeit in diesem jahr wir
wünschen dir eine schöne weihnachtszeit
freuen uns auf weitere spannende
projekte im nächsten jahr also wenn
klamotten von den tragen schon
zusammenarbeit ist dann gerne meine
haare hält pony ist wirklich fluch und
segen denn manchmal sieht das so cool
aus und manchmal mal gucken was ich denn
für die tolle zusammenarbeit
ich sage ich sage gerade dass es keine
werbung ist keine denkt sondern nur dann
schreiben sie zusammenarbeit
es ist nichts offizielles hier ich kann
werbung wegen markt nennung da oben hin
schreiben das mache ich
aha eine wind brennt ich glaube das gebe
ich meine nichte weil die handball
spielt und ich glaube sie kann das
besser gebrauchen dass wir sind
trainingsanzug dreier freu dich du
kriegst einen trainingsanzug zu
weihnachten paket nummer 2 habe ich
tatsächlich bestellt teamorders sind
unsere hobbys und zwar sind sie von der
marke opel moni opening ceremony und
weil ich jude law in kappeln sein will
dein schwanz
ich fand den mega cool und timo von
denen auch cool also haben wir den
beiden einfach bestellt er in xl und ich
in m und in opening ceremony waren wir
sogar in new york im laden drin und wir
fanden den mega cool aber die sachen
wahrheit teuer aber ich nenne sich mehr
sagen was er gekostet
der war auf jeden fall kraft reduziert
geilich wechsel vom schwarzen hose zum
schwarzen humor auf und dann hat man
hier noch eindruck 2002 aber mit viel
fantasie könnte doch 2020 stehen
guck mal welcher pulli angekommen ist
tranken wir sogar von seiner hiphop kool
g rap atreia paketes ist vom
ullstein-verlag aha
jonas hat ein eigenes buch geschrieben
ich bin wird es das lese ich bin richtig
gespannt was der da so runter
geschrieben hat ich bin sehr stolz auf
dich jonas viel erfolg auf jeden fall
noch mit dem buch und buch zu schreiben
ist von mir auch schon ganz lange ein
traum deswegen ist es so krass irgendwie
dass er das ja einfach gemacht hat ein
paket ist noch erreicht in dem paket
sind kopfhörer und mit denen mache ich
eine kooperation auf instagram grooming
gehört mein gott endlich auch ich wollte
schon eben mehr haben ich wollte jetzt
nur noch gute nacht sagen ich lieg schon
unter der bettdecke und ja wir sehen uns
morgen wieder morgen räume ich mein
arbeitszimmer und mein badezimmer auf
also stay tuned for des ich hoffe dieser
block war es irgendwie ja kann man kann
auch nicht jeden tag durch die
krassesten sachen erleben heute war halt
ein tag an dem ich drüber gefahren bin
und es also nicht jeder kann
gras und blogger jetzt zurzeit den dänen
nicht mehr
er wird okay aber der plant ja alles ist
ja auch nicht echt casey leistet
das stimmt nicht jeder kann damit
doppelt so gut
[Musik]
ja